pour le moment premier couple je vous
demande d'accueillir isabelle
morini-bosc c'est jean michel maire
d'arqués
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
les marchés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chérie ça doit leur là bas les apporter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m l'amour dans le pré il y avait le
persil qui sont inutiles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes très bon voilà la belle
isabelle isabelle en tout cas qu'une
fois de plus on a pu voir que vous étiez
m'a dit ah oui jean-michel je sais vous
avez décidez vous avez pris une grande
décision qu'ils avaient décidé d'autres
gradés vos interventions dans tpm pee
wee pour oui je vous le dis il va nous
en parle il va nous en parler dans
l'instant c'est terminé tout ce qui est
en dessous de la ceinture c'est terminé
c'est jean michel a décidé d'être le
bouc à giuly de maintenant de l'émission
c'est à dire il va toujours aller plus
haut dur à girac le bouquet vient
d'entrer la clotte de isabelle deuxième
couple et vous allez voter chez vous
quel a été le meilleur couple de dirty
dancing
jean michel et isabelle très très beau
vraiment bravo mais je trouve que tous
les deux vont bien match ce match c'est
normal c'est élégant
c'est dommage en tout cas faut surtout
que je n'en ferais tu si je peux
patricia en tout cas toujours prêtes si
je veux le faire à 100 couples career
frr que je l'embrassé dont j'ai toujours
très mauvais signe allez on y va
deuxième coupe kelly et maxime
[Musique]
cariat
[Applaudissements]
et
m
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
faire jouer huit ans
[Musique]
b
yahoo
en tant que président de la république
ouais
un battement la bisou sur le way i
heureusement c'était magnifique c'était
sympa n'y a pas eu chanter quoi une
portée c'était ce qu'on peut refaire un
juste un petit peu vraiment bas secondes
pour fait un peu la nôtre non pas le
porter pour l'instant c'est pas validé
voilà donc ce n'est pas valide n'est pas
une portée c'est pas importer la tournée
ça c'est surtout kelly qui saute et
laissez vous ne le sentez pas ne le fait
pas moi j'ai un peu parlé tout à l'heure
ouais mais il fonctionne j'ai peur qu'un
accident voilà maxime ce que vous le
sentez il n'y a pas le nom alors oui
merci
les mineurs ne sont pas bons c'est serge
houle est certaine
dans cette université